néanmoins alors c'était une partie des
missions nous avons pu constater comme
tout le monde tout simplement en
regardant la télé ou les journaux que
monsieur benalla apparaître très
fréquemment auprès du président de la
république et dans des missions qui sont
peut-être plus proche du déplacement
privé ou qui ne sont pas des
déplacements en province
cela signifie tout de même qu'une
certaine confiance a été maintenu en
monsieur benalla alors je comprend
d'abord je vais vous dire je comprends
parfaitement cette question et que ça
puisse vous interpeller là aussi je sais
que sur des faits précis on voit
apparaître mathieu benalla sur des des
images vous êtes posé des questions les
questions étaient posées au directeur de
cabinet et je vais y répondre également
à nouveau et à mon niveau en tant que
chef de service
il y as je crois quatre moments pour
lesquels et des interrogations sur la
présence de monsieur benalla sur un
dispositif engageant la présidence de la
république
on a plus parlé notamment de l'entrée au
panthéon de monsieur et madame simone
veil -le bien cette préparation je l'ait
prise en charge personnellement j'ai
fait la mise les missions préparatoires
ce qu'ils ont eu de nombreuses
c'est un événement très important j'ai
fait des missions préparatoires sans
monsieur bénin et le coeur du dispositif
le jour de l'entrée au panthéon ne
comprenait pas monsieur benalla puisque
j'y étais avec marie argouarc'h eu égard
à la taille de cet événement et c'est
quelque chose sur lequel nous avions les
idées très claires avec patrick strzoda
dès le moment de la rétrogradation et eu
égard à la nécessité de mobiliser tout
le monde il y a une mission qui a été
confiée à monsieur pénale à ce jour là
qui était de synchroniser l'arrivée des
cortèges
il n'a rien fait d'autre pas participer
à une mission préparatoire et n'étaient
pas engagés dans le coeur du dispositif